hello everyone and welcome to some more
rapid action un leaches We are
continuing our goal of uh uh getting
well becoming rided we have to play 20
games and we are I think at game number
10 uh and currently at
2154 so let's see uh who we get as as an
opponent for this
game uh and do we get okay we get the
white pieces and our opponent is Mr
verison E
so let's go for
E4 uh no
idea good luck hello yes good luck to
you too sir he goes for the Sicilian all
right let's
see uh D6 let's go for the some standard
stuff
here
okay how do we want to play against the
nidorf
uh this should be the most
fun let's go for this and let's
uh okay E5 very
nice if he goes H5 he really doesn't
want me to play G4 because that was kind
of my plan G4
G5 okay so he's not stopping yet but I'm
not sure I want to play it
now let's go with
G3 not maybe the most exciting way to
treat the the nid but
uh it has it has been done before I
believe not not sure about the G3
move uh but yeah usually uh G4 G G5 can
be very annoying for black uh let's just
continue developing blah blah okay
Castle he will at some point go
B5 yeah that's the that's the
moment Knight C6 all right let's put a
knight on
D5 always always a great
idea and next probably depending on what
he does probably Bishop to E3 but also
I'm looking at like King H2
F4 uh all sorts of uh ideas that will
get me to control more
space yeah so we'll see what it
does uh if he trades on D5 that's uh you
usually not the best for black so I'm
going to go with oh he trades on D5
okay very
interesting very interesting indeed what
why would you do
that
huh let's play
F4 I could prepare it with King H2 but
uh for the moment this one check doesn't
really do anything H but yeah probably
preparing it with King to H1 the king to
H2 was uh H I'm going to go with Bishop
captures simply because I'm still eyeing
that C6 Square for my
knight yeah I really like this Square
for my knight and now that he developed
his Knight he's kind of inviting me to
go
there and the D6 Pawn might become weak
although it's not yeah that's why I play
King H2 first of course of
course
um yeah not
terrible there's still no actual way for
him to stop Knight C6 uh other than
Knight back to B8 but that would just be
silly he'll probably play a rook C8 and
then once I go Knight C6 then bring the
Knight to B8 uh but then of course the
bishop on E7 is
unguarded
so yeah not loving this for for
black yeah Knight captures here maybe
no simply eliminating the defender but
Bishop captures will
still yeah probably some Rook E8 stuff
here uh but yeah the D6 Pawn will uh
will now be even oh he he will give up
the exchange I yeah I'm not buying that
I'm not buying that at
all so we don't want to capture okay we
can't capture but even if we could we
wouldn't want to because Rook d8 will be
problem for
us all right so he sacrificed The
Exchange I have this wonderful past Pawn
here I would very much like to keep it
uh he's threatening to capture
it so we give up the bishop
here probably and that will make it very
hard for him to actually go after after
the opponent let's play
A4 A4
yeah hoping to get a rook into the game
if he plays B4 then we're going to
develop the queen and get the Rook into
the
game uh the other way around yeah E4 now
hm yeah that's annoying that's
annoying might even be annoying enough
to give up give the exchange back
ah why are you so
annoying yeah I'm really not interested
in giving up the C6
Pawn
huh yeah not the best not the best all
right so I think I made a few suboptimal
moves here maybe it could have been done
better
uh yeah let's take
it take it and capture here he can take
the B2 Pawn but I don't think it's as
important plus I get Rook B1 attack the
bishop then the B5 Pawn will fall he
does have this one check I can just go
back with the bishop so nothing really
he he'll probably throw in a rook d8 uh
although I don't think this is all that
impressive um yeah okay he does have the
queen and Bishop controlling d8 so I
can't uh okay so he does go for one
check
once the pawn comes to C7 this is as
good as
over he has some threats with Bishop E5
maybe but again I don't think
it's don't think it's enough I can even
go for Queen
F3 yeah my Pawn should become two po
okay now this is interesting do I
sacrifice the queen we always have to
ask this question Queen captures a
bishop Capt captures Rook goes to A8
only way to defend is for the queen to
defend let's say queen F6 and then C7
wins yeah unless I'm blundering
something which I don't think I am
that's
game
okay very nice or he might yeah Bishop
captures Rook eight
chck King
f8 I capture King E7
C7 huh oh yeah Queen B6 that's also a
move Queen B6 oh I missed that
one Queen B6
ouch yeah but we're still good we're
still good I
think still
works still
works yeah he'll get the king into the
game now but it doesn't
matter okay I I overlooked Queen B six
but still
works still works because of
this or does
it
huh huhuh
huh why you do
this
yeah C7 was better I think as well I
think C7 was better as
well
yep we don't really have a good move
here yeah he's going to go there okay
still we go
here still we go
here
oh okay so we can't allow him to capture
this Pawn that's for sure only how do we
how do we how do we actually stop
it
yeah
okay so he allows me to get my queen
into the game I managed to trick him a
little bit but he will Checkmate
Me Maybe I don't
know he already wrote GG but I don't
think it's GG just
yet okay so he let let us back into the
game okay so now once I get my queen
into the game he's going to be up two
pawns I'm going to capture this one he's
going to capture this one and
then yeah Bishop's of opposite color
he's still winning
this but I can make it I can make it a
bit more difficult now so let's let's do
our
best yeah you had to do that
unfortunately do we do we gain anything
from one more
check not
likely
uh
yeah
I'm definitely taking this
one uh yeah I'll go here simply to be
able to block this with the
bishop
yeah Pro yeah in that uh moment where I
played Rook to
A8 uh preparing C7 I should have
probably played C7 first and then yeah
if Bishop captures Rook eight will be
made and that's how I would have win win
the bishop as
well that was a
yeah which you know I'd probably see if
I didn't miss queen to
B6 okay so what does he want here uh
if I go here he wants to trade Queens
with Queen
F4 and if I go here can I any way to
stall
this yeah okay this at least maybe gives
me a fighting
chance cuz now this this this I go here
yeah at least at least like
that okay so he will go for
checkmate very very
nice and why wouldn't
he yeah why wouldn't
he
yeah yeah nicely connecting with the
pawn yeah I got nothing here I've got
nothing
here a he will pick up the this one
first before trading Queens I'm just
going to stop the immediate Queen
trade uh with Queen C5 and now he will
probably be able to do it some other way
but still let's let's try to make it as
annoying as possible okay so he does get
it okay so now you've heard that Bishops
of opposite colors are a draw not so
much when your opponent is up three
connected pass pawns so now we'll see
how he checkmates me all right my only
hope my only hope and you should
probably resign such positions but
uh my only hope is that he somehow
stalemates
me uh but chances are he will just
Checkmate
me okay let's uh move our Bishop let's
not go to a dark
Square
go
here let's go
here
okay let's go here let's try and trick
him oh no I made a mistake oh no don't
take my Bishop no he he sees
it he sees
it don't do
it have to
move okay so got checkmated right there
but uh let me just check up until this
this point
uh as we do make a short analysis on
every game like okay this is perfectly
fine fine fine even G3 is
fine yeah okay three fine fine fine
maybe yeah Knight D5 this is fine fine
okay so
G4 uh with the G5 always the idea it
would seem yeah Bishop
captures
so no weird stuff here all these were
all fine moves yeah and this is not even
completely winning for
me uh yeah this was F okay so A4 a bit
of a waste of time yeah because it
allows Pawn to E4 yeah queen queen E2
just prevents
the uh E4 so I don't have to give back
the
exchange okay so this is now pretty much
equal but yeah this is now a draw ah C7
right away C7 right here yeah that's
sad yeah C7 and after he captures Rook
to A8 with check of course and now you
have to give stuff back and of course
now we just Checkmate to the black king
wow that's super sad yeah and again I
would probably see it if I didn't uh
miss queen to B6 I only saw Queen to f
six for some reason but yeah now Queen
B6 and still it should be a draw but B
before the move that always wins the
game here loses the game G6 and now okay
I did try a little bit but there was no
way to actually do it here he allowed me
to get uh my queen back into the game
but still it's winning for him nothing
to be done
here good game Mr ver on E uh should
have should have played better on more
than one occasion
uh so what are you going to do big
congratulations and yeah thank you all
for watching I will see you soon uh with
some more rapid action un
leaches